February is the month of love in
PlayStation Plus is giving us some extra
games to snuggle up with if you're a
subscriber and want to know what you can
grab for free here's what's coming in
February much like in January ps4 is
first game is actually three games in
one the Bioshock collection includes
Bioshock Bioshock 2 and BioShock
Infinite letting you explore both
rapture under the sea and Columbia in
the sky if you've never played the
trilogy before you're in for an
adventure full of gunfights special
powers and lots of plot twists ps4
second game is much less violent it's
The Sims 4 in case you're unfamiliar
with the Sims here's the pitch you
create characters with individual styles
personalities and goals then play out
their lives family friends activities
jobs and all sorts of hijinks are at
your fingertips but wait there's more
and it's another violent one PlayStation
VR owners can also grab firewalls
zero-hour this month this 4v4 tactical
shooter sees one team defending a
sensitive package while the other has to
capture it firewalls next map will also
be added to the game the same day that
the S Plus lineup goes live and those
are your free PS Plus games for February
they'll be available from February 4th
through March 2nd remember that you can
always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles on GameSpot and
stay tuned as we report on the new PS
Plus lineup every month
[Music]